je suis à chambry une petite ville à
côté de laon dans l'aisne et je suis ici
pour rencontrer une orthophoniste au 16
septembre lendemain de l'obligation
vaccinale elle a cessé son activité elle
va nous raconter pourquoi
bonjour marie clothilde merci de nous
recevoir lors on est ici devant votre
cabinet qui n'accueille plus aucun
patient depuis près d'un mois maintenant
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi bonjour
écoutez c'est à cause de l'obligation
vaccinale à laquelle je ne veux pas me
soumettre mes entrées je vais vous
expliquer tout ça
comment est ce qu ils font tous ses
enfants tous ces adultes maintenant que
vous n'exercez plus alors pour les
enfants autistes c'est vraiment très
compliqué puisque à distance je ne peux
pas vraiment les aider et puis c'est
vraiment très spécifiques comme
rééducation par contre pour les enfants
de maternelle qui ont des retards de
paroles ou des difficultés
d'articulation et puis aussi pour les
enfants qui ont des difficultés dans
l'apprentissage de la lecture je donne
accès aux parents en fait mes vidéos
didactiques donc j'ai une chaîne youtube
qui s'appelle ortho astuces que j'avais
déjà créé depuis quelques années face à
la liste d'attentes qui est considérable
chez nous on était très étonné parce
qu'on pensait pouvoir faire de la télé
orthophonie
puisqu'au premier confinement on a eu le
droit de faire de la télé orthophonie et
là on nous dit non il faut absolument
vous faire vacciner donc là je ne
comprends pas
qu est ce qui fait qu est ce qui a
motivé cette fois de ne pas vous faire
vacciner exactement donc c'est déjà une
confiance qui a été rompu en décembre
2020 donc par rapport à la politique
sanitaire 1 quand le gouvernement n'a
pas enlevé les masques pour les enfants
à l'école ensuite les critères à chaque
fois pour décider les mesures changent
et on ne sait plus à quel saint se vouer
je ne peux pas avoir confiance on a en
un vaccin qui est encore à mêmes
conditionnelle et puis pour lequel on
n'a pas suffisamment de recul maintenant
on nous dit qu'il faut une troisième
dose l'efficacité n'a pas l'air non plus
absolu on sait qu'on peut contaminer
encore les autres personnes en étant
vacciner donc pourquoi m'obliger à faire
un vaccin si je peux toujours contaminé
les enfants que je côtoie je préfère
faire un test pcr tous les trois jours
on est dans un désert médical ici dans
cette région oui tout à fait à nos
médecins partent progressivement tous à
la retraite on a un peu de personnes qui
s'installent à nouveau dans la région ça
fait 23 ans moi que j'exerce ici quand
j'ai commencé je n'avais pas de listes
d'attentes déjà et au fur et à mesure on
a une liste d'attentes qui s'agrandit un
an deux ans d'attentes on ne peut même
plus dire le délai en fait aux personnes
actuellement
avec votre fils pierre lys c'est ça à
qui donc vous fait l'école à la maison
racontez nous un petit peu pourquoi pour
sa décision de faire l'école à la maison
à votre fils mon combat contre le masque
à l'école pour les enfants puisque je
fais partie de plusieurs collectifs
notamment collectif de parents collectif
de pédiatres et un collectif
d'orthophonistes dernièrement on avait
signé un manifeste de plus de 100
orthophoniste qui témoignaient des
difficultés d'apprentissage que pourrait
avoir l'enfant donc à cause de ce masque
à l'école en juin
quand j'ai découvert en fait que le
masque n'était pas enlever aux enfants
malgré le fait que l'épidémie baissé et
qu'on rouvre est tout rond rouvray les
restaurants et cetera j'ai décidé donc
de faire l'école à la maison et de
retirer mon enfant du système scolaire
qu'est ce que vous avez comme comme
solution interne j'espère que je vais
pouvoir reprendre mon activité
d'orthophonistes tout en n'étant pas
vacciner sinon et sinon et bien
il faudra se reconvertir puisque je ne
souhaite pas me
soumettre à cette obligation
jamais je ne peux pas dire jamais le
retour des tests pcr ci soit à nouveau
mais bon ça avec un certain coût du jour
même oui alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de je pense de professionnels
de santé qui serait prêt à payer 1 les
tests pcr et allait rentrer dans nos
charges ans c'est tout à fait possible
je pense que moi je serais tout à fait
d'accord pour faire cela